the video you were in a very special to
tell us a bit about it it was called new
voices and a group of us just spoke
about the various things that we believe
are happening now that are movements
that have caught fire and inspire a lot
of hope for people not only in this
industry but I think everywhere in the
country in the world specifically what
has made you get so involved and why you
say this passionately
well I was one of the first people to
speak out against Harvey Weinstein this
fall in Ronan Pharos the our core piece
and since then it has become something
that I I've always been an activist on
women's rights I was a stop bounce
against women campaign a pastor for
Amnesty International for three years
I'm a goodwill ambassador of the United
Nations about the crime for unit
trafficking but this was personal and
now I'm getting much more involved in
trying to create solutions to bring more
more equality and fairness and safety to
the work place not only for people in
Hollywood but everywhere how difficult
was it for you to come forward and and
do you feel like it give gave other
people's strength it was very difficult
for me to come forward personally it was
very very hard I wrestled with it for a
long time
consequently I felt that I had to do it
and I'm so glad that I did I do feel
that the more of us that came out the
more strength that's given to other
people who have been victims of sexual
misconduct harassment or assault or
abuse and I've gotten a lot of feedback
from people that it it helped them to
have other people voice what had
happened to them because it sort of
brought that forward and everyone join
the me2 movement which was started by
Toronto Burke
way back when but but we're all grateful
to her for having started it but it's
kind of a revolution of humanity in a
way that this sort of thing that has
gone on since caveman times since
forever rape and sexual pressure and I
think we have a chance in our generation
in our lifetime to change the equation
for everyone and it's super exciting and
do you think that do you think that the
Oscars set the right tone this evening
do you think there was enough politics
enough of the issues we discuss you know
I mean some people are going to say
there is too much some people say they
were too little I thought it was
wonderful I thought there was a very
good feeling a very sort of human spirit
to it
it didn't have too much of a highbrow
impossible' aesthetic it felt more real
and fun
something about when Jimmy Kimmel went
into the other audience you know
everybody gave treats to the people
there and Surprise them I don't know I I
think it had a very lovely warm feeling
to it and very inclusive a lot of
diversity I think the awards were sort
of spread around two different movies it
wasn't all one movie but I was so happy
for Pierre Mendell tomorrow my dear
friend I was so proud of him and so
happy true I'm so grateful thank you so
much for your time thank you